my real resolution though is to do a
life-changing event
this year what does that mean chris
positive something good something's
positive what's what what counts as a
life-changing event
sounds really bad like breaking my arm
for fun but like
i know like making something or doing a
challenge like doing a really crazy
challenge
right it's like amazing and wow it's
very vague isn't it
how about you please help me with ideas
in the comments how about a race across
japan
something really big a really stupid and
awesome that will
define me for the rest of my life
they'll definitely that is mine
that's like a [ __ ] massive goal
because how would you defend yeah i was
about to say don't be
too over ambitious right like that's
talking about over ambitions
why not why not i'm i've only won this
year i want chris to have his own nhk
show i want chris on tv
but it's going to be
interview thing where you go up to like
random foreigners in japan and go are
you youtuber
on what anything anything animated
anything i don't [ __ ] know if the
offer comes up and it's like i don't
care if it's like youtube based or anime
based or i don't know i can just imagine
joey the university of tokyo needs your
help
we need anime to the experts
i've seen so many tedx talks where i
just like there's
not a whole lot of like educational
value it's just fun the problem with ted
talks in general is that they'll
often propose a problem like the world's
going to end and they'll make you
depressed
and then you're kind of waiting for a
solution like well then they're like
good luck with that everyone and then
the walk off stage it's like
you've told us the problem great what's
the solution i don't feel like they
don't do that enough a lot of ted talks
my favorite one is when they talk about
something like 20 minutes
and they segue into the actual topic and
there's like three minutes left those
are my favorite ted talks
but that's what i've noticed right like
a lot of tedx talks are just kind of
let's get this person who's really
passionate about something and just make
them spew their passion for 15 to 20
minutes
well i i think uh adam savage did a
really good one right about yeah he's
cosplaying love letter to cosplay it was
really good that was really good yeah
i haven't seen that one yeah it's it's
basically him just saying like yeah i've
been to
uh comic cons and comic conventions for
the past like 15 years and i've always
cosplayed
at one of them so apparently there was a
i forgot which one it was but there was
like i think it was like new york comic
con or something where he cosplayed as
um uh no face from spirited away you
know in that one it's like a full-on
costume
yeah and because the character doesn't
talk no one knew was him
until after the convention when he said
yeah that was me that's true
and everyone was like but i talked to
you and took a photo with you what
that's pretty cool didn't brian cranston
cosplay as brian cranston
from like breaking bad like no no you
like like the actual no no he wore like
a brian cranston mask
and like one of the comic cons and like
you know wore like the ball to white
yeah
costume just walked around and no one
knew it was brian cranston
we gotta cook jesse he's like wow you do
a really good impression
oh my god that'd be cool i guess my new
year's resolution is
to get a schedule for my uploads i think
good one good one appreciate it you've
as long as i've known god there has been
a a
like mystical schedule somewhere that
exists in the sky
i mean i can relate to you what what
dictates your schedule because my
schedule used to be really chaotic
yeah right now like before okay so there
was my schedule before trash taste and
then after trash taste
and before trash taste i there was less
of a schedule but at least i could
guarantee hey
i will make like at least two videos a
month and it will come out and now it's
just
okay i finished the video um i don't
know when the next video is going to be
and uh yeah it's i mean my personal
schedule
this year especially for the last six
months has been like way more chaotic
compared to my entire five-year career
and like you youtube
you managed to get a schedule for trash
days in six months and you've been doing
your own channel for 13 years
you still can't get a schedule going oh
boy it's weird talking to joey and
connor and hang out with them and like
and hearing how you can be ahead of the
schedule
and have videos planned out ahead and
i'm just like what is this five head
move that i've never heard of before
i mean like that would just [ __ ] that
would freak me and stress me the [ __ ]
out if i
brought out a video and i had nothing
else ready yeah
welcome to my world joey yeah well
welcome to my world i don't know how you
two do it
like well the pressure's on to make the
videos count
do you not feel like though like the
moment like you can't enjoy your weekend
or whatever because sometimes you're
just worrying about like [ __ ] i haven't
got the video done
yeah yeah that that is that is a big
problem that i'm trying to solve
like i see you guys on weekends i'm just
like well these guys don't like stress
about making videos at all i i try i try
to
video i'm gonna try at least saturday
and sun
and maybe sunday off but always try at
least take one day off yeah right don't
do something yeah
i normally always fail i yeah i always
try and take at least like
two days off like it doesn't have to be
a weekend just any two days within the
week just
a day where i'm just not working on a
video not planning anything just
chilling doing hobbies or whatever maybe
i should just change otherwise
i mean like simpler videos like me just
reacting yeah chris
reacting to people reacting to chris but
here's the thing it's like
at least my personal goal for 2021 of
youtube is to be like a lot more
ambitious in my videos but the the
problem with more ambitious
why are you laughing what do you mean
like as in like videos that take more
vibration to like actually
film and kind of construct and you know
a lot more like narrative based i guess
that
requires a little more preparation than
just writing a script or
just flicking on a camera and starting
to talk right yeah um
but the problem is with that is that if
i want to also maintain a schedule which
i would like to
then i also have to plan things way
ahead of time as well
right so like as of right now i am like
about a month and a half ahead in terms
of videos
yeah i have like yeah i know right
that's my exact reaction like the next
video filmed and i've got to edit it
yeah i've got like another two ready to
go but yeah i've already filmed like six
videos
it's just waiting to get edited because
i think hanging out with you guys i've
realized i've just kind of
normalized working every day and then i
realized that's just not normal
right